le tu l'as vu parce que je veux ième
tour et des réponses d'amour donc c'est
le tu l'as vu jingle alors il avait
plusieurs justin bieber on verra ça on
va se retrouver dans quelques semaines
façon j'espère pour une semaine mais la
c b n'a jamais qu'on en parle c'est vrai
que benalla donc il a était au sénat
pour se défendre et beaucoup beaucoup de
questions sur lui et donc est une
question qui étaient un peu amusantes
qui a été il paraît que vous avez été
cet été avoir perdu deux gardes du corps
de gens de télé réalité notamment ayem
nour et ses enfants au maroc
alors est ce que c'est vrai ce que c'est
pas vrai il ya une réponse très violente
qui a été non c'est faux je ne peut pas
diriger ce que dit la presse people
grosso modo il ya des fêtes news et il a
dit je ne suis pas tombé aussi bas c'est
très violent évidemment pour ayem que
j'embrasse et du travail j'entends avec
elle ou non lorsque c'est vrai ce que
c'est pas vrai aujourd'hui d'après moi
j'aime questionner ayem directement il
m'a répondu ce matin déjà les hypers
choqué en fait des propos de bena n'a
pas voulu s'exprimer dans la presse
voilà parce qu'elle voulait pas lui
donner de la crédibilité de l'importance
maintenant il la vit aux crochets de
certaines personnes actuellement il est
tombé bien bas
ayem ne veux pas parler pour pas comment
dire le elle veut pas donner un coup à
quelqu'un qui est déjà à terre
aujourd'hui donc il a décidé de passer
les allumés par douglas délire je pense
que benalla il a quand même été très
loin dans ses propos aujourd'hui qu'ils
aient été ou qu'il ne l'ait pas été
quand tu es gardes du corps et quand tu
t'occupes de la sécurité de quelqu'un tu
n'as pas à juger qui il est et à tout
cas merci au premier
je sais pas quel sera le gros dossier du
jour saisi par adrien quand on voit la
part dont je parle aussi en régie on va
d'abord on va d'abord voir les images de
justement des benalla et puis derrière
on ne dirai pourquoi pourquoi vous ne
croyez pas regardez ce renseignement
vaut ce qu'il vaut mais vous savez qu'à
peu près dans tous les jours n'est
intéressé par la question il vous après
été prêté une activité de garde du corps
qui a été peut-être momentanée ou
inexistantes vous allez nous dire auprès
d'une star de la télé réalité je suis
pas tombé aussi bas malheureusement non
j'ai eu aucune activité professionnelle
depuis que j'ai quitté l'elysée ait eu
un certain nombre de faits qui nous qui
sont sortis pour j'ai pas la maîtrise
des médias
donc je laisse ce passé il ya eu un
certain nombre de nos conclu monsieur
bel et bien j'ai bien compris je pouvais
mais il a profité aujourd'hui à profiter
de certaines de certaines de certain
confort kayem peut avoir d'accord il à
profit sa très très bas aujourd'hui qu'
il est pour dire mais c'est pas la crise
où le débat c'est parce que y est mais
quelqu'un bio pas quelqu'un de bien on
l'a doha m
non ma question c'est est-ce que oui ou
non il a déjà rencontré oui les étés
dans le même avion pour aller au maroc
cet été c'est là que les gens ont cru
nous la principale on a cru qu'il était
garde du corps parce que c'est son
métier
ils allaient dans la ville un de vincent
nickelés donc de l'ex mari l'ex mari
d'ayem donc forcément on s'est dit c'est
lui qui paye le vert du corps etc et il
avait des projets pour travailler avec
lui alors lui joue sur les mots dits je
pète et garde du corps d'ayem c'est vrai
la bête et gardes du corps parce
qu'apparemment ils devaient peut-être
faire un contrat de vincent nickelés qui
n'a peut-être pas fait kilari d'ayem on
était dans l'avion c'est peut être une
cause il a voyagé en même temps qu'elle
pour y aller en dinars dont il peut pas
dire au sénat il était d'ailleurs
politique il est pas garde du corps
enfin bref nicky loh plaindre benalla il
était à l'elysée en train de protéger le
président de la république en lui est ce
que vous ne vous occupez de gens de télé
réalité il dit je peux pas passer du
président de république
les prix de la sueur et de répondre
quand même été monté en épingle par ayem
et c'est elle qui a fait chuter les
informations et évidemment
évidemment que alexandre belle anna qui
n'était pas garde du corps du président
mais qui travaille à la présidence de la
république ne va pas devenir garde du
corps de ayem elle a profité de ça pour
faire le buzz ça parce qu'ils n'ont tout
ça parce que parce que il a rencontré
son mari ou son ex-mari peut-être pour
des affaires ou pas ils peuvent se
rencontrer maintenant tout ça a été
monté en épingle et je comprends qu'il
ait cette réaction
selon vous c'est lui la victime et c'est
ayem qui s'arrêter sujet pour demander
aux gens que senti je pense qu'on s'en
fout on a parlé pendant deux heures de
laetitia et moi je m'en fous aussi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chaque instant je m'en fous j'ai battu
pour le coup ayem y ait vraiment pour
rien on est dans l'histoire c'est dena
là c'était vincent mickeler qui voulait
le rencontrer pour des affaires et que
c'est lui ou crochets moi je vois la
voix j'ai eu beaucoup de soucis avec
ayem
mais pour le coup alors oui énormément
de soucis avec ayem le coup alliés pour
rien d'accord elle a bien démenti la
rumeur oui mais les curieux à l'évidence
c'est qu'il arrive ils tombaient les uns
bas il a très bien que ça fasse un peu
lumière sur lci elle en joue un peu
c'est plutôt bonne mais attendez mais
vous rigolez le sait même pas exprimé
qu'elle a pas parlé
le dossier n'a même pas pris vous
connaissez très bien alors on attend
tous est la reine du snap chat et à la
ddt d'or ce qu'elle a refusé ce pour moi
j'adore c'est une copine et pourquoi ce
qu'elle a refusé de venir sur ce plateau
ou même de faire ce qu'on appelle un
fender de par l'eau le cachet et non pas
le canal est maligne la coopération tout
le truc me l'a dit il ya aussi des
affaires avec dans son amitié et elle a
ptet pas envie de s'exprimer pour être
mal à l'aise dans son huitième jour
prime pas on a peut-être l'impression
que c'était vrai c'est que quand on
parle pas bien on fait ça crée tout de
moi je suis comme si elles avaient
toutes ces vies c'est n'importe quoi
l'histoire s'arrête à paul